hallo Krimifreunde ich bin Stefan
Netzeband und ich bin Toni Heyer und
unser sommer-spezial mit Re Uploads geht
weiter yes heute gibt es zwei Fälle die
die Ermittler besonders ratlos gemacht
haben wir beginnen mit Maria Böger die
2010 entführt und ermordet wurde und
durch die wirklich schlimmen
Fehlleistungen der Polizei gerieten
zwischenzeitlich sogar ihre liebsten
unter Verdacht ihr hört dazu gleich auch
ein erschütterndes Tondokument in diesem
Podcast und auch der zweite Fall hat
eine Familie an die Grenzen ihrer Kräfte
gebracht wir starten aber mit der
Geschichte von Maria Bürgern
hallo ich bin Natalie Strauß gemeinsam
mit Mirko Kasimir werden wir auch heute
wieder ein kriminalfeuer besprechen der
uns beide gefesselt hat hallo Natalie
und ein herzliches Willkommen in unserer
Podcast Hörer ja stimmt es gibt
Kriminalfälle die Jahre nachwirken wegen
ihrer besonderen Dramatik und schlicht
und einfach weil sie nicht gelöst wurden
und um genau so einen Fall handelt es
sich bei der heutigen Podcast Episode
heute im Jahr 2023 liegt die Entführung
von Maria Böger 13 Jahre zurück bei der
Beschäftigung mit dem Fall sind mir
sofort die Bilder aus der Fernsehserie
Aktenzeichen XY ungelöst von damals
eingefallen aber was ich sagen wollte
der Fall Maria Böger und der Appell der
Familie an die Täter ging mir sowas von
animieren
und zwar Mutter Maria Bürger wir fliegen
sie an die für uns alle Situation
positiv zu beenden
bitte lassen Sie uns wissen wo sich
unsere Mama befindet das ist die pure
Verzweiflung sie flehten den Verbrecher
an der seit damals zwei Tage nach der
Tat bis heute stumm und unauffindbar
geblieben ist bis heute lässt mich das
auch immer noch nicht kalt Mirko wie ist
es denn überhaupt zu diesem
erschütterten Fernsehauftritt der
Familie Bögerl im Jahr 2010 gekommen es
ist Mittwochmorgen der 12 Mai 2010 ein
Frühlingstag im schwäbischen Heidenheim
beginnt Thomas Bürger der Chef der
örtlichen Sparkasse ist schon bei der
Arbeit seine beiden Kinder Christoph und
Carina Böger studieren und sind auch
schon außer Haus die 54-Jährige Maria
Bürger die Ehefrau von Thomas und Mutter
der beiden Kinder ist somit allein mit
den Alltagsdingen im Einfamilienhaus und
auf dem Grundstück das bis an den
kleinen Fluss Brenz heran reicht
beschäftigt Maria Bürgern eine
sportliche attraktive Frau mit blonden
Pagenkopf ist von Beruf eigentlich
Sonderschullehrerin aber seit einiger
Zeit Hausfrauen in der Nachbarschaft ist
sie allen bekannt aktiv in der Gemeinde
und dem Tennisverein sie pflegt ihren
großen Garten und die anderen Anwohner
schätzen ihre Gastfreundschaft doch an
diesem Frühlingstag wird das schwäbische
Kleinstadt idyl zerbrechen und Familie
Bürger in einen Strudel aus Verbrechen
Behörden Versagen hoffen und am Ende
Hoffnungslosigkeit gezogen
Maria Bürger wird an diesem Morgen
entführt die oder der Täter müssen den
Tagesrhythmus der Familie genau
ausgespielt haben sie schlagen zu als
sie sich sicher sein können dass niemand
ihnen in die Quere kommt und so bekommt
auch keiner in der Nachbarschaft etwas
von einer Entführung oder ähnlichem mit
so lange bis Thomas Bürger der Direktor
der örtlichen Sparkasse einen grausamen
Anruf annimmt
um 11 Uhr 23 läutet das Telefon von
Thomas Böger eine Männerstimme weist ihn
im breiten schwäbischen Akzent drohnt
daraufhin dass seine Frau entführt wurde
300.000 Euro lösegelt sein fällig und
bis 14 Uhr zu übergeben sonst würde er
seine Frau nie wieder sehen
sparkassenleiter Thomas Bürger bleibt
auch in dieser wahnwitzigen Situation
und trotz seiner Aufregung ein
kontrollierter gradliniger Mensch und
informiert sofort die Polizei er
berichtet über das gegebene Zeitfenster
für die Lösegeldforderung des Entführers
den benannten übergabeplatz in der
Autobahn A7 und dass dieser mit einer
Deutschlandflagge gekennzeichnet werden
soll dann erwähnt er in seiner Aufregung
und in aufkommender Panik dass er das
Lösegeld eventuell selbst und möglichst
schnell besorgen könnte
diese Idee aus Panik und Angst geboren
führt zu einem ersten schwerwiegenden
Fehler in den Ermittlungen ein Fehler
der im Verlauf der Geschehnisse zu einem
Desaster wird kurz zum Hintergrund bei
Lösegeldforderungen kümmert sich die
Polizei über den Dienstweg um die
verlangte Geldsumme die dann wie von den
Erpressern gefordert in Stückelung und
Verpackung übergeben werden kann es gilt
immer zuerst das Entführungsopfer zu
retten sind die Opfer dann in Sicherheit
führt die Spur des Geldes oftmals dann
auch ganz schnell zu den Tätern aber im
Fall von Maria Bürgern verlässt die
Baden wirken Bergische Polizei diesen
vorgegebenen strengen Ablauf bei
Entführung weshalb die Heidenheimer
Polizei sich damals über den Leitfaden
hinweggesetzt und es so zulässt dass der
unter psychischen Druck und Angst
agierende Ehemann des Entführungsopfers
die Geldbeschaffung übernehmen darf das
ist bis heute unklar
vielleicht ist es ein naives Vertrauen
in den Bankangestellten oder schlicht
Bequemlichkeit niemand redet es ihm aus
niemand von Seiten der Behörden ergreift
die Initiative um das vorgegebene
Verfahren einzuhalten und die
Angehörigen aus der Ermittlung
herauszunehmen dazu zitiert Carina die
Tochter von Maria Bürger später den
ermittelnden Soko Chef so wenn ein
Bankdirektor das nicht können wer dann
weiter erzählt sie später in einem
stern-Interview man kann sich nicht
vorstellen was diese Menschen meinem
Vater zugefügt haben indem sie ihm die
Verantwortung für die Geldbeschaffung
übertragen
es ist wirklich unglaublich dass das in
einer solchen Situation zugelassen wurde
Thomas Bürger wird von den Stuttgartern
Nachrichten dazu so zitiert ich habe nie
darauf bestanden das Lösegeld selbst zu
besorgen der Betrag wurde besorgt mehr
möchte ich dazu nicht sagen
es ist richtig dass ein leitender
Angestellter wie Thomas Bürger bis zu
einer Summe von 300.000 € Auslagen
selbst gegenzeichnen kann vermutlich
weiß das auch der Täter und setzt daher
die Lösegeld zu mir in genau dieser
maximalen Höhe an so erklärt sich
vielleicht auch das schmale Zeitfenster
von nur wenigen Stunden bis zur Übergabe
der Täter kennt vermutlich das Verfahren
und spürt dass es schnell gehen muss nur
es gibt ein gewaltiges Problem bei der
Geldbeschaffung Thomas Bürger bekommt zu
viel Geld in seiner eigenen Filiale in
der vom Entführer gewünschten Stückelung
gar nicht zusammen
allein beim auftreiben des Lösegeldes
geht damit wertvolle Zeit verloren
Ortswechsel zu dieser Uhrzeit fährt
gerade Maria Bürger als Sohn Christoph
aus der Uni kommend Richtung elterliches
Haus
er hatte sich nur gegen 10 Uhr 30 mit
seiner Mutter zum Mittagessen verabredet
mit der Information sie müsse nur noch
einkaufen fahren verabschiedete sie sich
bei ihrem Sohn wie war heute wissen für
immer als Christoph gegen 11 Uhr 20 am
Haus der Familie ankommt ist das Auto
der Mutter eine kleine schwarze Mercedes
A-Klasse nicht in der Auffahrt der
Garage geparkt Christoph macht sich
keine Sorgen die Mutter wird bald zurück
sein und dann können sie gemeinsam
kochen doch irgendwie dauert alles viel
zu lange und kurz nach 12 ruft Christoph
das Handy seiner Mutter erneut an wer
gew
ünscht zurzeit nicht erreichbar bitte
versuchen Sie es später noch einmal
meldet sich aber nur der
Anrufbeantworter kaum aufgelegt Klinge
Christophs Handy ein Rückruf aber nur
die Nummer seines Vaters erscheint der
ihm daraufhin eine schreckliche
Nachricht überbringt Christoph was ganz
schlimmes ist passiert das darfst du
niemanden sagen
die Mama ist entführt worden
ich mag mir gar nicht vorstellen wie es
Christoph und kurze Zeit später auch
seiner Schwester Carina wohl mit dieser
grausigen Botschaft gegangen sein muss
ich meine das sieht ja schlagartig den
Boden unter dem Füßen weg
aber noch haben sie Vertrauen in die
Arbeit der Polizei gehen solche
Entführungen nicht meist glimpflich aus
außerdem wissen sie alle dass ihr Vater
alles daran setzen wird dass sie alle
gemeinsam sicher aus dieser Situation
wieder herauskommen werden aber Thomas
bürgerl ist mittlerweile ziemlich
verzweifelt da er wie Mirko schon
erwähnt hat im ersten Anlauf das
Lösegeld nicht auftreiben kann und in
der Folge auch keine echte Hilfe der
Polizei bekommt
Thomas Bürger macht sich mit einem
Kollegen und seinem Dienstwagen auf den
Weg ins 30 km entfernte Ulm dort ist bei
der Bundesbank Filiale niemand über die
Dringlichkeit der Geldabhebung
informiert man denkt es ging um einen
Blitzkredit und hat schlicht keine
Ahnung von dem Laufenden führungsfall
also gibt es auch keinen Grund die
Mittagspause ausfallen zu lassen so
bekommt Thomas Bürger die lösegeldsumme
erst gegen 13:45 Uhr in seine Hände das
Zeitfenster zur Übergabe schließt sich
nun bedrohlich schnell selbst unter
Missachtung aller Regeln im
Straßenverkehr ist es für den
verzweifelten Ehemann von Maria Bürgern
nicht mehr möglich bis 14 Uhr bei der
vorgegebenen Übergabestelle an der
Autobahn A7 anzukommen
erst 15 Uhr 27 Uhr legt Thomas Bögerl
das Lösegeld erschöpft an der
angegebenen Behelfsausfahrt ab und
markiert es wie vom Entführer verlangt
mit einer Deutschlandflagge und nun
heißt es bangen und warten
anderthalb Stunden Verspätung bei der
Geldübergabe und auch keine weitere
Kontaktaufnahme durch den Entführer das
hört sich nicht gut an und das ist es
auch nicht jeder Kriminelle würde in
diesem Moment denken dass sein Plan
geplatzt ist und sich schleunigst aus
dem Staub machen Beweise vernichten
etwaige Zeugen verstummen lassen doch
bei dem Bürgers gibt's noch Hoffnung
nachdem das Geld abgelegt ist trifft
sich die ganze Familie im Haus die
Anrufe auf dem Handy der Mutter laufen
mittlerweile nur noch in die Mailbox
Polizisten beginnen erst gegen
Mitternacht 12 Stunden nach der
Entführung den Tatort auf Spuren zu
untersuchen
die Polizei steht der Familie zudem
einen Betreuer zu Seite der soll vor
allem eins nämlich sie beruhigen aber
das Warten ist eine Qual die Empfehlung
der Polizisten sie sollten alle ins Bett
gehen und sich ausruhen ist hohen in den
Ohren der völlig verstörten Angehörigen
die sich mehr und mehr im Stich gelassen
fühlen
auch scheine die polizisten der
Spurensicherung in dieser Nacht ihren
Aufgaben eher missmutig nachzukommen sie
gehen nicht auf Hinweise der anwesenden
Kinder und des Ehemanns ein untersuchen
weder Terrasse noch Garage finden in den
Augen der Familie nur Ausreden um sich
aufwendige Sicherungsaufgaben zu
ersparen offiziell befindet sich schon
einer Ermittlungsteam im Aufbau viel zu
spüren ist davon aber nicht immer wieder
vertröstet man die Familie dass es schon
wird die Polizei schätzt den Täter
intern als unprofessionell ein als
Idioten und man meint der will sein Geld
der holt das wenn es dunkel ist und
tatsächlich wird am nächsten Morgen
gemeldet dass das Geld verschwunden ist
anscheinend hat die Polizei Recht und
der Fall erledigt sich in den nächsten
Stunden von selbst aber kann die Familie
jetzt endlich aufatmen das klingt doch
nach einer guten Nachricht nach der
versäumten Möglichkeit pünktlich das
Lösegeld abzuliefern wäre es großes
Glück wenn der Täter das Geld nun doch
abgeholt hätte damit stünde der
Freilassung von Maria Bürger ja nichts
mehr im Wege oder Mirko ja das würde man
meinen aber es kommt leider alles anders
schnell stellt sich heraus das Geld
würde nicht vom Täter weggeschafft
sondern von Mitarbeitern der
Autobahnmeisterei gefunden und abgegeben
damit sind die Hoffnungen auf ein
schnelles und gutes Ende der Entführung
dahin und nun kommt Bewegung in die
Ermittlung die Polizei nimmt wenn auch
spät ihre Arbeit im großen Maßstab auf
und beginnt mit einer weit gefächerten
suche im Umkreis von Heidenheim hunderte
Beamte durch Streifen das Gelände
Spürhunde und Hubschrauber kommen bei
der Suche nach Maria Bürger zum Einsatz
erfolglos
nicht ganz Mirko du hast recht man
findet zwar nicht Maria Bürger selbst
aber am 14 mai also dem zweiten Tag der
groß angelegten suche Aktion werden das
Handy der entführten und ihr kleiner
A-Klassen Mercedes gefunden beides sind
völlig unterschiedlichen Orten aber
immerhin zeigt es dass die im Fokus
stehende Region die richtige für die
Fahndungen ist das gibt den Ermittlern
und der Familie Auftrieb das doch noch
alles gut wird allerdings werden
Blutspuren in Maria Bürger als Fahrzeug
sichergestellt die zumindest auf eine
Verletzung der entführten hindeuten und
man kann zudem DNA Material eines
möglich Qualität das isolieren genau das
wird später noch wichtig aber erstmal
wird der gute Lauf genutzt und die
Ermittlungsbehörden zünden die nächste
Stufe am 16 Mai 2010 wird ein
Verdächtiger festgenommen aber nachdem
sich ein Verdacht nicht erhärtet auch
schnell wieder freigelassen nun beginnt
zudem die Bildung einer Sonderkommission
aus 80 Mitarbeitern mit dem Namen Flagge
die SOKO stellt am 18 mai vier Tage nach
der Entführung von Maria Bögerl eine
Belohnung von 100.000 € in Aussicht viel
Geld für Hinweise die zu Ergreifung des
Täters führen nun arbeitet die Zeit
gegen die Polizei mit jedem Tag der
vergeht und an dem man nichts von der
entführten oder dem Entführer hört
steigt die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass der
oder die Täter die Nerven verloren und
die Opfer beseitigt haben Hoffnung gibt
allerdings das noch keine Leiche oder
Spuren eines Tötungsdeliktes gefunden
wurden
und deshalb greifen die ermittelnden
Behörden auf eine besondere Art der
Kommunikation zurück da am 19 Mai 2010
ohnehin eine neue Sendung der beliebten
ZDF-Reihe Aktenzeichen XY ungelöst im
TV-Programm steht entschließen sich die
Behörden und die Familie Bürger eine
direkte Ansprache an die möglichen
Entführer zu richten und das ist genau
das was ich ganz am Anfang dieser
Episode erwähnte an diesem
Fernsehauftritt kann ich mich noch so
gut erinnern und ich bekomme bis heute
immer noch eine Schauer da sitzt ein
völlig übernächtigter Vater mit seinen
beiden erwachsenen Kindern blass und
vereint zwischen Zimmerpflanzen der
Appell an den oder die Täter wird zu
einem flehen und betteln das einem durch
Mark und Bein geht
dennoch wird der Text sehr aufgesagt und
wie sie später noch herausstellt hätte
die Familie vielleicht eine andere
Ansprache gewählt aber die Ermittler
trinken auf die ausgestrahlten
Formulierungen wird die Familie Bürger
wenn uns jemand offen an den Führer
unserer Mutter Maria Bürger wir fliegen
sie an die für uns alle zu qualvollen
Situation positiv zu beenden bitte
lassen Sie uns wissen wo sich unsere
Mama befindet
bitte geben sie uns auf irgendeinem Weg
ein Zeichen sie können auf vielen Wegen
anonym Hinweise geben rufen Sie beim
vertraulichen Telefon an es ist absolut
vertraulich es wird nicht überwacht
bitte Sie können sich darauf verlassen
oder wenn sie sich an irgendeinen Fries
der das zum Schweigepflicht verpflichtet
aber bitte schreiben Sie eine E-Mail wir
haben sie einen Brief in einem
Briefkasten geben Sie uns ein Zeichen
für unsere Mutter ist wirklich an bitte
bitte tun Sie es bitte bitte
mir als Mann ich appelliere
Menschlichkeit und unsere tiefe
Bezahlung bitte helfen sie lassen sie
Mama
Fragen kommen bitte bitte bitte bitte
eine Flut von Hinweisen die meisten
unnütze überschwemmt die Polizei darauf
hin
aber einige Dutzend Hinweise erweisen
sich als relevant und denen muss sofort
nachgegangen werden aber alles erfordert
Zeit und Personal nur die oder der Täter
melden sich nicht Maria Bürger meldet
sich nicht es gibt keine neuen
Lösegeldforderungen nichts es ist ein
düsteres Schweigen das sich über das
Verbrechen legt das Schweigen der Toten
die Familie stürzt sich in Aktionismus
die Kinder gehen selbst von Haus zu Haus
von Ort zu Ort und befragen die Menschen
ob sie etwas gesehen haben sie denken
das doch jemand in der Kleinstadt etwas
mitbekommen haben muss dieses eigene
Handeln ist für die Unglücklichen Kinder
und den Ehemann die einzige Möglichkeit
mit dem Wahnsinn umzugehen
die Polizei sucht großflächig weiter und
es kommt durch Zeugenaussagen auch zur
Erstellung eines Phantombildes des
Möglichen Täters das zeigt einen n30er
mit dunklen langen Haaren die zum
Pferdeschwanz gebunden sind man hatte
ihn im Umfeld des Familienhauses der
Bürgers und zufälligerweise auch an
jener Behelfsausfahrt an der A7 wo das
Lösegeld hinterlegt wurde gesehen dort
soll der Mann versucht haben per
Anhalter mitgenommen zu werden doch dann
verliert sie jede Spur okay ich fasse
mal zusammen knapp eine Woche nach der
Tat fehlt jede Spur der entführten und
hat aber ein Phantombild des Möglichen
Täters viele Hinweise und eine Familie
die sich über die Medien im Großen und
auch im ganz kleinen Umfeld extrem in
die Ermittlung involviert hat doch
nichts bewegt sich
nun werden die großen sucheaktionen im
Umkreis von Heidenheim zurückgefahren
man meint hier nichts mehr finden zu
können die Ermittlung konzentrieren sich
auf die Suche nach dem Täter auf Basis
der Hinweise und auf den Fakten aus der
Spurensicherung vergeblich ja das ist
frustrierend für die SOKO Flagge und ein
Martyrium für die Familie und dann
wendet sich der Fall am 3 juni geht ein
Spaziergänger mit seinem Hund in einem
Waldstück ca 10 km von Heidenheim
entfernt Gassi der Passant geht diese
Strecke öfter der Hund schnüffelt wie
immer herum doch das Tier verhält sich
diesmal komisch und schaut in einem
großen Haufen aus Reisig und Essen herum
der Spaziergänger tritt näher heran und
findet die verwesende Leiche einer Frau
sofort alarmiert er die Polizei und die
bestätigt kurze Zeit später dass die
entführte Maria Böger tot aufgefunden
wurde die Familie Richter auf ihn
zusammen die schlimmsten Befürchtungen
haben sich bestätigt es ist vorbei
die Obduktion ergibt dass die Ehefrau
und Mutter vermutlich mit einem großen
Küchenmesser erstochen wurde eine
grausige und kaltblütige Tat die
Anteilnahme in der Bevölkerung bei den
Nachbarn und in der ganzen Region ist
groß aber das tröstet die Familie nur
wenig denn der Fundort der Leiche liegt
in einem Gebiet das gleich zu Beginn der
Ermittlungen mehrfach von der Polizei
durchstreift wurde warum fand man sie
damals nicht warum wurde die Leiche erst
später dort abgelegt das ist eine
wichtige Frage handelt es sich um einen
polizeiversagen dass die Leiche in den
ersten Tagen nicht entdeckt wurde oder
hat der Täter die Leiche erst dort
abgelegt als sie begann zu verwesen
das ist aber unwahrscheinlich vermutlich
ist es schlicht so das Lösegeld wurde
nicht pünktlich gezahlt der Täter macht
seine Drohung wahr verletzt die
entführte Frau tödlich liegt sie dann
unter den Ästen und dem reise ich am
Waldrand ab er schmeißt ihr Handy
unterwegs weg und stellt das Auto der
Ermordeten auf dem Hof eines Klosters ab
dann verschwindet er zu Fuß oder mit
Hilfe eines Mittäters so simpel so
grausig während die Familie trauert
ermittelt die Polizei weiter in den
führungsfällen werden oft auch die
familiären Verhältnisse durchleuchtet
und so rücken die Hinterbliebenen in den
Fokus der Ermittler es gibt Gerüchte
nach denen Thomas Bürger der Ehemann der
Ermordeten eine Geliebte haben soll
diese nun Zwillinge erwartet und ihn um
Geld erpresst weiterhin werden die
Kinder verdächtigt mit der Entführung zu
tun zu haben Telefondaten des
Anschlusses der Familie Bürger werden
ausgewertet angeblich gab es demnach
noch steuergespräche mit dem Entführer
aber es stellt sich heraus dass die
Anlage falsche lokfalz gespeichert hatte
dann meldet sich ein anonymer Anrufer
bei der Polizei der angibt dass Thomas
Bürger das Lösegeld durchaus hätte
schneller auftreiben können aber nicht
wollte all das wurde durch die Medien
gestreut und diese Form der
Berichterstattung heizte diese Gerüchte
damals leider mit an es dauerte nicht
lange und die Familie gerät immer mehr
unter Beschuss und damit in die
Defensive da die Polizei mit ihren
Ermittlungen nicht weiterkommt richten
sich alle Augen der Öffentlichkeit auf
das Leben der Hinterbliebenen Thomas
Bürger hätte dem Druck nicht mehr stand
und begibt sich in stationäre
psychiatrische Behandlung bis es ihm
etwas besser geht doch zu Hause wird er
wieder von seinem Verlust überwältigt
und sieht ein Jahr später nur noch einen
einzigen Ausweg Selbstmord am 11 juli
2011 wird der zweifache Vater und Witwe
er hängt im einen Sportraum seines
Hauses aufgefunden ein knapper
Abschiedsbrief richtet sich
ausschließlich an seine Kinder der Tod
seiner geliebten Frau die schleppenden
Ermittlungen und die Presse hat trieben
ihn immer weiter auf einen Abgrund zu
bis er nicht mehr ausweichen konnte das
ist wirklich ich kann es nicht anders
sagen richtig beschissen dieser Mann
zerbricht ein Jahr später am Verlust
einer geliebten Person und an den
Umständen der Ermittlung und der
Behandlung des Falls in der
Öffentlichkeit es ist wirklich grausam
und für die beiden Hinterbliebenen
Kinder ein unvorstellbarer Verlust
nachdem sie eh schon alles verloren
haben
ja da bleibt man wirklich sprachlos
zurück das ist auch der Grund weshalb
mich dieser Fall heute noch so bewegt
obwohl er schon mehr als 10 Jahre
zurückliegt mir hilft bei solchen
schrecklichen Dingen nur mich auf die
Fakten zu konzentrieren und es gibt noch
ein paar Fakten zu diesem ungelösten
Fall nachdem klar ist dass die Familie
nichts mit der Entführung zu tun hat
ermittelt die Polizei weiter sie wird
bei den Ermittlungen heftig von den
Hinterbliebenen Kindern kritisiert
durchaus zurecht und man gibt
Versäumnisse diesbezüglich später auch
teilweise zu einer wirkliche heiße Spur
ergibt sich aber erst sechs Jahre nach
dem Mord knapp sechs Jahren nach dem
Wort an Maria Bürgern geht die Polizei
noch einmal 150 neuen
ermittlungsansätzen nach
es ist 12:30 Uhr und damit sind wir
zurück bei den N24 Nachrichten an diesem
Donnerstag Nachmittag der Fall Maria
Böger nach der Entführung und dem Mord
an der Bankiersfrau sind die
Ermittlungen wieder in vollem Gange nach
einem öffentlichen Fahndungsaufruf gab
es auch wieder Hoffnung dass einer der
bisher spektakulärsten Kriminalfälle
Deutschlands vielleicht doch endlich
geklärt werden könnte aber kurz vor 12
Uhr lösen sich diese Hoffnungen
er Tatverdächtige nicht der Mörder von
Maria Bürger sein könne der Abgleich mit
den Spuren vom Fundort der Leiche war
negativ
im Gespräch mit zwei jungen Männern an
einer Bushaltestelle in Hagen gibt er
laut der Ermittler Täter wissen Preis
die Zeugen nehmen alles mit dem Handy
auf
47-jähriger tatverdächtig aus
Königsbronn konnte festgenommen werden
doch ein genabgleicher gab jetzt die
DNA-Probe bei dem Festgenommenen stimmt
nicht mit der an Bürger als Auto
gefundenen Erbsubstanz überein so die
Ermittler und er sagt auch sofort aus
sich nur wichtig gemacht zu haben und
sein Täter wissen reine Fantasie sei
mord verjährt nicht und zu ermitteln
auch noch heute mindestens zwei Beamte
weiter sie gehen neuen Hinweisen nach
die auch heute noch gegeben werden ihnen
geht es darum einen Täter dingfest zu
machen und seitdem Opfer auch die würde
wiederzugeben aber es ist einfach mit
dem Verstreichen der Jahre immer
unwahrscheinlicher geworden erfolgreich
zu sein
deshalb vielleicht auch die Aussage
eines der aktiven Ermittler
es wäre nach sechs Jahren eigentlich
schade wenn wir den Fall nun mit Glück
lösen würden sagte er wir hoffen auf
einen Arbeit Sieg aber wenn Kommissar
Zufall um die Ecke kommt geben wir ihm
die Hand
wow Natalie was für ein krasserfall der
leider bis heute kein Ende gefunden hat
was macht diese Geschichte diese Familie
Tragödie mit dir es macht mich ehrlich
gesagt fassungslos aber auch
gleichzeitig total wütend weil
meines Erachtens nach müsste doch so
eine Geiselnahme total professionell
ablaufen das ist ja wohl etwas was die
Polizei kann das ist so mein Gedanke
dahinter das Geld wird geschafft die
Frau kommt wohlbehalten und gesund
wieder zurück und deswegen verstehe ich
gar nicht wie diese langsame Arbeit
überhaupt von standen gehen konnte die
Polizei hat den Mann oder hat sich der
hat die Familie sich selbst überlassen
und war so wie es scheint keine
wirkliche Hilfe und hat es zu spät
richtig aufgedreht
gleichzeitig denke ich mir auch wie kann
man so kaltblütig sein ja eine Familie
auszuspielen die Mutter zu entführen ja
dann 300.000 Euro zu erpressen ich meine
man macht das ja wenn man das Geld will
und nicht weil man ein kaltblütiger
Mörder ist oder und dann diese Frau
umzubringen überhaupt gar kein Spielraum
dafür zu lassen dass die Kohle
vielleicht irgendwie später an geschafft
wird oder oder ich bin einfach auf beide
Seiten so wütend und die Familie tut mir
einfach nur leid Mirko was lässt dich
denn bei dem Fall nicht los ich finde
diesen Fall auch absolut er schulternd
diese unglückliche Verkettung der
Umstände dieses hoffen und bang dass die
Familie total zum Not hat da noch der
mediale druckte den Vater dazu getrieben
hat sich selbst das Leben zu nehmen es
ist eine absolute Tragödie die eine
ganze Familie zerstört hat
natürlich ich sag dir nach all dem
schrecklichen und tragischen was dieser
Familie widerfahren ist da kann man
wirklich nur hoffen dass die Polizei aus
solchen Fehlern und diesen
Nachlässigkeiten gelernt hat und dass
sowas nie wieder passieren wird
und natürlich bleibt letztendlich die
Hoffnung dass man den Mörder irgendwann
dingfest machen kann und seine gerechten
Strafe zuführen wird wir danken euch
fürs zuhören und hoffen dass ihr bei der
nächsten Folge wieder dabei seid bei
Tatort Deutschland Spezial euer Wirkung
und eure Natalie den Fall Maria Bögerl
erzählen wir mit Artikeln aus der
Bild-Zeitung NTV Stern Stuttgarter
Zeitung und Esslinger Zeitung sowie mit
einem Ausschnitt aus Aktenzeichen XY
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Haier
Produktion serdar-